>> Let me welcome
our first panel.
It's moderated by
Robbert Dijkgraaf.
Robbert is Director of the
Institute for Advanced Study.
Before he was president of,
so let me make sure I
have the words correctly,
The Royal Netherlands Academy
of Arts and Sciences.
Actually, not quite imaginable
for us, in the Netherlands,
he is a regular TV star
which imagine into US,
somebody who heads
a scientific institute
being a TV star.
Well, he is.
He also wrote a book
which is called,
The Usefulness of
Useless Thinking.
>> Useless Information.
>> Was it thinking?
>> Knowledge.
>> Knowledge. Of
Useless Knowledge.
So, we rip of
the title a little for
our first panel which will be
The Usefulness of
Long-Term Thinking.
So, let me welcome to the podium,
Robbert and his
panelists Matt Jackson,
Yael Kalia, Madhu Sudan
and Eva Tardos.
>> Switch on your mic.
Good morning.
It's a great pleasure
to have this panel.
Of course this would start by
congratulating Jennifer
and Christian,
everybody here from Microsoft
for this wonderful success.
So, you now have
a teenager and I say
good luck with that,
I say as a parent,
the teenage years are
very challenging,
but I'm hopeful that we
see many wonderful things.
Such a great pleasure to welcome
you to this first panel,
with this wonderful title,
"The Usefulness of
Long-Term Thinking," or
the technical title was
The Usefulness of
Long-Term Thinking at 9:00 AM,
which is a challenge.
I must say, when we
issued the book and
I talked about
this useless knowledge is,
one of the jokes
was in this time,
now in this political climate,
we need a prequel
which is the usefulness
of useful thinking.
Perhaps we need a children's
version of that where
we're coloring plates or
something to make clear.
But I think this will
be very exciting,
we will be talking,
I must say also we were
instructed to set the bar not
too high in our first panel so
that the other panels can shine.
But in some sense we
are doing something
quite special because we
will be thinking about
thinking, and about theory,
the role of theory,
and in some sense also in
this great environment
that's created here.
Clearly, both Jennifer
and Christian,
I know you have
something with theories,
I don't know what it but you are.
So, let me just briefly
introduce my panel members.
So, start here with Yael Kalai.
She is, actually, you're local.
Some sense both here at
Microsoft and also at MIT,
computer scientist, cryptography
is one of your fields.
Then a lot of more or less local,
Madhu Sudan of course to
theoretical computer scientist
worked on many areas proof
checking et cetera,
now at Harvard.
Then Matt Jackson, Professor
of Economics at Stanford,
behavioral economics game theory,
these are some of your interests.
Then finally, Eva.
Eva Tardos at
Cornell mathematician,
combinatorial mathematics,
album rhythmic game theory,
that's some of your interests.
So, a lot of brainpower
here onstage.
I think I wanted to start by
asking each of you to say,
if perhaps to share
one example of
a unexpected advantage of
thinking of theory that
you perhaps came as
a surprise to you too?
Madhu can I start with you?
>> Oh, my God.
>> Yes.
>> I thought you were
going to in order.
>> No. I saw you relaxing.
So I had to intervene.
>> I must confess, I'm
also somewhat jet-lagged.
>> Yes.
>> From the west coast since
I was about to go to sleep.
So, good thanks for waking me up.
>> So, it's 6:00 AM for you?
>> Some of you may know, I have.
>> Oh, yeah. We should be
closer to the audience.
That was one of my goals,
to connect to you.
>> Okay, great. So, I had been at
Microsoft a few years
in the past,
five years at least.
Yet my biggest contribution to
Microsoft was not any
of my own look here,
but rather a student
that I contributed to
the Microsoft Research
Environments of a cannon.
Now, he had been one of the
most purest of theoreticians
that I ever knew.
When Silicon Valley made
the mistake of hiring him,
I wrote to them,
thanking them for
their generosity.
This is obviously going to be so
useful to him and to
the world of theory.
It turned out that once he
was in Microsoft research,
he started getting engaged in
problems related to
storage on the Cloud.
Over time along with the very
group of active researchers
and was very important
that theory was not
sitting isolated on its own,
they started interacting with
other researchers trying to
understand what are
some challenges
in distributed storage,
you want your data to-
>> Can you tell us a little bit
what theoretical ideas
were that he brought
to the problem?
>> So, the whole idea prior
to his involvement in
this research was if you
wants to replicate data
so that you can live
with crash failures,
you must just completely
identically replicate
things everywhere.
People that are aware
of the idea of error
correcting codes which
don't usually do
this blind replication but
somehow try to recover from
falls by more efficient methods.
But they always thought that
this is contradictory to
the idea of recovering the data
very quickly after a failure.
Sergei brought in
this perspective
coming from the world of theory,
that instant recovery of
data or fast recovery of
data is not in contradiction
with sophisticated
storage mechanisms.
You put the two together,
very soon everybody realizes
was actually practically viable.
>> Could you just say
that the assumptions be,
immediately sharing comes
to mind,.Or something?
It's interesting
that the fields of
information something
was also born in theory.
>> In theory. Absolutely.
In many of these cases,
we have seen somehow
periodically time and again,
that when you abstract
the problem come up with
some very complicated
long-term vision of,
this is how I want to solve
problems in the limit,
you also end up with matching
complimentarity instantly.
In Shannon's paper
is probably one of
the first error-correcting
codes, actually reported.
That was just a by-the-way,
we can also do these things
concretely and
throughout there is
this myth synergy between
the theory and the practice that
of course on the one hand,
you want to think about
the long-term limits,
at the same time,
you cannot help produce
useful work for the near future.
>> I'm not skipping you, but
some examples from your field.
>> Yeah, sure. There are several.
I think the one I want to point
out is one of probabilistically
checkable proofs.
So, when I was a student of IT,
in one of my classes
about this idea,
of probabilistically checkable
proofs. What are these?
Very counter-intuitive,
check them line by line,
you verify this and
verify this and so on.
Probabilistically
checkable proof,
you have a proof you
just read a few bit.
One here, one here, random
locations, read them,
then present them to decide
if this thing worked out.
Turns out, you can do
that reading in
three bits, in three bits,
you're going to get a
probability one minus p.
So, actually when a
student, I got this,
Madhu was one of
the pioneers of his words,
he wrote a very nice
survey about it.
I read it, I was just
[inaudible]. In theory of course.
Who will generate the proofs,
the proofs completely
uses a lot of
algebra and it seemed like
a really nice-working theory.
Everybody thought it was
a really nice-working theory,
which clearly will not have
any applications in practice.
There are a lot of theory that I
hadn't thought were beautiful but
what people didn't like about it,
it's very far, practically
we'll never do it.
Hey, these are used in
many of the cryptocurrencies
that are out there,
that has been implemented,
there are many groups that are
working on it right now
and try to optimize.
Turns out, it does
really well in practice
when it is used.
So, this is one of the
techniques that seemed, it's on.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> No, I got that.
Anyway, it's truly really
remarkable of all things-
>> Is that other way
of saying that,
you said this is
an interesting fact because,
in some sense,
contrary intuition.
Is that the theme of our theory
that in some sense it might
actually removed some of
our national bias that we have.
Because I think in certain areas,
we have very little intuitions,
so it may need deep
mathematical complexity.
>> Right. I don't know
if it's a theme or not.
>> Yes.
>> It's a very, it's
a good question.
>> I also want to ask
you about cryptography,
because there's a great number
theorists who say often,
they're the replications of
number theory to cryptography.
Is that these are basically
very difficult problems to solve.
>> Right.
>> So, he made this point
that number theory is always
seen as the complete,
the hardest sentence the
most useless thing ever,
and that's why it's so beautiful.
This method instance has
and he wants to solve
these number theory
problems to liberate
his beloved numbers can you
say something about it is.
How component mathematics it is.
>> Right. So, actually
that's a very good point.
Actually, Number theory is
a very good example of
something our problems.
The fact that something's hard.
Okay. What is useful in that?
That I have a conjecture
I can't solve.
It turns out that
all cryptography based on that.
Without that, we
wouldn't have crypto.
So, and that the very
actually basic example of,
and yeah, all of
cryptography is based on,
and most of it on Number theory.
Some of it an elliptic
curve style which is
also analytic form
of Number theory,
and it's all based on
how conjectures and
the hardness of problems
that people don't
know how to solve.
So, yeah actually if he
succeeds in his mission,
I'll be out of the job.
>> I don't want to turn to you.
Continue with the session,
I feel this is
theory [inaudible].
You have to be confident
as this is something that
social sciences are
a very interesting domain.
What- what examples
did you bring for us?
I think as somebody in
the social sciences,
it's fairly obvious now that
Game theory has been transformed,
[inaudible] able to really
understand and structure a lot of
problems where people
have different interests,
they come together and all
different settings and interact.
If you trace back
the real seminal contribution,
it was John masses.
1951 paper where he basically
set up the problem.
So, if you look for that Von
Neumann and Morgenstern
really started giving in the 20s,
but they sort of,
set the structure.
They set the structure in
terms of zero-sum games,
and it was very elegant
mathematically,
but it didn't- wasn't
the right setting to actually
apply to many settings
where people have
interests but they're
actually gains from interacting.
So, most of the
situations we're in
there the fact that
we come together,
we act their synergies,
we're better off acting
together than apart.
So, zero-sum games don't capture
99 percent of the
settings we're in.
In Nash, basically
set the structure of,
he proved existence of
an equilibrium point,
but the more fundamental
contribution
was just setting
the problem up and saying,
"Here's the action spaces, here.
People can take
different actions,
they get payoffs from these,
we set it up, and now
we find a solution."
The fascinating part about it was
if you look at what was
going on in the 1950s,
this was a branch of mathematics,
and social scientists were
completely separate from it.
Nobody had any idea
that this was going on,
and if you fast forward,
you go into the say
the 1970s and 1980s,
that's when it started
to be picked up.
It wasn't really, if you
look at say the 1980s,
you'll see papers by
say Milgrom and Weber
that use this to then
develop understandings
of how auctions work.
In an auction, somebody's
selling something,
there's different buyers
evaluated at different things,
there's different values
that can come out of that,
that's not a zero-sum game.
If you get it in
the right buyers hands,
it's more valuable than
wrong buyers hands,
how do they bid
against each other.
So, this gave them the tools to
understand that and then
fast forward again,
and you look at
the spectrum auctions
run by the FCC and so forth,
and those are based
on these theories.
After Nash won the Nobel Prize,
he had mental illness
for quite a while and he
was completely out of it,
and he'd never seen what had
been developed from his theory.
There was an interview with
Roger Myerson interviewed
Nash after the Nobel Prize,
and he asked them,
"Isn't it amazing that
your theory has come so far
and now it's basically
transforming
the way that we'd study things,
and things like auctions
are now being done,
analyzed using your structure?"
He said, "What do auctions
have to do with it?"
He had no idea of the connection.
Sometimes when
we're doing theory,
it's very hard to see where that.
>> Was the purest of
pure mathematics.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh. It's like
the other girl I knew
who over described his theorem
to [inaudible].
>> Exactly. It's
just a fixed point.
>> It's just a fixed point.
>> Exactly. Just cut
the time that you
know who cares about it,
and somehow it was
the abstraction and
the clean structure that was very
flexible that made it powerful,
and once eventually,
the social science could
make use of that framework,
that's the real contribution.
>> There is a saying
nothing less useful as
the Group theory,
that's a good example.
>> Though, I guess I was
thinking of something maybe more
boring and one thing and
some of the examples
we've just seen so far,
but given that you actually
introduce mathematicians,
I have met this to see as
someone with a Mathematics PhD,
but I stopped thinking of
myself as mathematician a long,
long time ago. So, maybe that's.
>> I want to create
some diversity that come.
The four theoretical
Computer scientist.
>> I didn't back off,
but made me switch to CS
instead of Pure
Mathematics was thinking
of and I like the idea the
Maths or the theory
that you still
love has some connection
to applications.
That was very appealing,
and that's basically about it,
and it may seem that maybe
it's more fun to work on
these maths problems than
be more abstracts in.
And I guess, the fact
that our theory of
applications is more
that everything that
all fields that
faced theoretical Computer
science in the globe.
Sometimes, the application
is visible right away,
and sometimes we get
criticized that it's not
sufficiently visible.
One classical the area of
where this happens alone,
it's approximately
happens for 20,
or 30, or more years,
is approximation algorithms. So.
It turns out to be
computationally hard
than a series or
a [inaudible] ideas that,
"Okay, how close can I
get to the optimum?"
Certainly, in early years,
there was a thought
of this- this missile
office [inaudible]
whatever, who cares?
This is coming back as a theme
over and over again sort
of along the lines that you all
mentioned in
the different context.
If you use very powerful
mathematical tools
in early years,
the problem was that
people using a programs.
Nowadays, they're using
some scarce even worse,
and then it turns out
these are actually useful.
At the moment, there are some
I can't watch for it yet,
but I think it's going to
happen but [inaudible]
programming-based month we now
have very much faster solvers
for that special kind of
linear programs that
tend to get views
and they turn out to be very
useful as actual tools.
Beyond actually
the sort of tweaking
the algorithm and
the guarantee translator
that you heard,
and maybe that's sort of
the bigger point here.
These algorithms tend to offer
an understanding of what's
going on behind them
that very often an
approximation algorithms work
leads to algorithms that really
worked much better than
the theoretical guarantee.
So, going back to
the classical example I used,
the linear programming baseline
or a single convex
optimization baseline.
Convex optimization comes with
a [inaudible] duo even though
it's principle I could
only the proof this is
two approximation or a four
approximation of something [inaudible].
In any particular instances,
something in my hand [inaudible]
solution that gives me,
I prove that this
is a factor of two,
but in this application,
it's 10 percent up,
or this application
it's five percent
up that leads to
much better algorithms than
[inaudible] guaranteed
gifts [inaudible]
because they offer
some sort of understanding.
Oh in the last 10 years,
or maybe more 10,
I have been working
a lot in games theory
and this approximation
algorithm framework got
translated into what's
over there refer to
the price of energy that
is taking the system,
trying to understand how much [inaudible]
[inaudible] with social welfare.
It's a little bit different than
the approximation
algorithm because
often the price of energy
is not explicitly, in fact,
it's more explicitly suggests
they should or
shouldn't do something,
rather than, [inaudible]
what you should do it.
Traffic raw I think is kind
of okay doing it selfishly,
because it's not
so much worse than
the optimal then
it's reasonable to
don't bother with designing
raw things like very careful
raw things systems the sort
of everyone choosing a
short the [inaudible].
What we are missing
and I hope we're going
together is analog from
approximation algorithms,
where can evaluate
individual [inaudible] -
then we ca evaluate [inaudible]
happen in approximation algorithm,
almost all approximation
algorithm.
[inaudible] on data
and we can prove it.
We have a example base
a guarantee how good it is,
and at the moment there are
very few examples of this sort
of thing price of energy
on a particular instance.
But we do examine developing
field and I guess this is pushing
more abstract theories
to be something
electrically large
directly [inaudible].
>> [inaudible] examples from a theoretical
computer science [inaudible] ,
is there something perhaps on
you quite right something
to fill people's minds,
because either the usefulness
of something or it is
the intellectual depth
become asset 200 percent.
So, if there's something
almost occurs or usefulness
in the sense that,
if you're working so what
he feels [inaudible]
clear this has great applications
that you have to fight somehow,
to also developed
the theory behind it.
>> So, I try to reflect
on your question.
I think at the end of the day,
what's is very useful?
Often these are just beautiful
ideas [inaudible] ,
it's a beautiful idea
and sometimes when
your goal is just to get
something out there now,
"Oh, I want them to
be the fastest now."
You're not actually
looking for something,
you're just going to
solve this in that.
It's not about
a beautiful idea and I
think the things that
last, I don't know,
to me is like it's just the
beauty of the idea.
>> Can I dig
a little bit with you?
Because I kind of noticed that
really hear on the
[inaudible] we will
use beauty and beautiful ideas
and we all agrees I
think [inaudible] room.
I notices like arc is don't dare
use that word anymore [inaudible].
So, if you think about
a beautiful idea,
aren't you go secretly
already seeing that
this will have ramifications,
or can you just try
to put your work,
how you would capture that view?
>> Yeah. So it's a good question.
So, since you're
asking, can you define
what beautiful means [inaudible]?
It's a tough one.
>> But this one know [inaudible] from
other ideas [inaudible] central idea.
>> Yeah. I can tell
you what in some sense
what does not [inaudible].
It's something that
I'm solving a question
that's there now that
needs to be solved,
but if someone else doesn't
kind of nothing left.
If I [inaudible] seen solving but
somehow something at
a different approach
and he does better?
What I didn't becomes useless,
or not interesting anymore.
That's not a beautiful ideas.
A beautiful ideas,
even when someone
else does it differently,
and it's better than me, they
[inaudible] still lives,
and if it's really a good one,
a "beautiful one" then it will
find it's place elsewhere.
>> So, it's long term usefulness.
>> It's long term usefulness.
>> [inaudible]. Ma'am, I want to
ask a question about economics,
because [inaudible] and host
with a friend of mine who studies
medieval alchemy et cetera.
[inaudible] just-
Sometimes in economics,
it's like hype or science.
[inaudible] somehow people can
be captured by
the models, et cetera.
So, the models are determining
the real-world. Is
that your way around?
If for anything like this,
or with overshoot so to say,
or theory or models in economics.
Because in the end,
you're also dealing with
the real world and
determining people's lives.
>> I think that
what's important in
any field is to
understand where models work
well, and where they don't.
Understanding exactly how fairly
simple economic systems work.
If you increase people's wages,
where they're going
to spend the money.
If you are changing tax rates,
what's going to happen
to labor supply.
These kinds of things
are well-understood.
They're not sexy, they
don't appear in the news.
But the kinds of things that
people are interested in is,
when's the next financial
crisis going to hit.
That's hard to predict.
Now, you've got
a very complex system.
You've got all kinds
of interacting things.
The modeling is not very good.
People are going to be willing to
stand up there and give opinions.
By its very nature, people
have to make predictions and so,
economics is used as
a predictive science as well
as one to basically
understand systems and
to evaluate policies.
But I think its
strengths are not in
the areas that
appear in the media,
but more in areas that
are nuts and bolts
kinds of things.
If you want to
design a new system
for getting out of a program
in a developing country.
What's a good way to incentivise
people to participate?
These are kinds of
questions where
economists are making
progress and so forth.
It's very different
from predicting
the next world recession
or these kinds of things.
So, you get this idea that it's
alchemy and so forth
from looking at people,
pontificating and going way
beyond the reach of the models.
But there's areas where the
models apply very well.
>> It reminds me, I saw another,
I think was in Nature
of Science for a
few months ago and the title was,
Machine Learning is
the New Alchemy.
I want to ask all
of you a little bit
about the world of
data, et cetera.
Since many of you have a
background in Computer Science.
I mean that's a wonderful field,
because of someone had
started in theory.
It's a bit theory, and codal,
et cetera and binary
is fascinating,
started with negative
results something
and then in latitude
is blossoming field.
Now, we also live in a world
of big data and Machine Learning,
AI or something, where it
looks almost like you can fit.
Why do we need theory anymore?
If at some point we have
a machine that will be
fitting patterns and if
you want to start the discussion
around that topic.
>> First of all, we want
to input models that we
understand things as,
really give us an insight of
when are these things
working and when
are these things
not, then it can't.
This can't be excellent example.
Since, they're not this
very simple games,
theoretic setup, it doesn't
always fit the right word.
In fact, I see no economists
would claim that it does.
I hope I'm allowed to say this.
Yet, the fact that at
national equilibrium,
it has immense impact,
because it's such a simple theory
and so much insight is
really coming from this.
Machine Learning at this point is
less good in understanding
where the limits really are.
I hope that in the next,
what the time scale is,
let's say 10 years,
or understanding of what
this Machine Learning
systems can do,
and what are the limitations,
will it have
an immense improvement.
Machine Learning
is really popular
right now and a lot of
people are thinking
about trying to develop
a better theory and I
really hope it's happening.
I don't claim that
or not even hope,
that this theory
will fully explain
exactly what
Machine Learning can do.
The the same way, [inaudible]
alone doesn't fully explain
the whole economy,
[inaudible] admit it.
But it'll offer a
basic understanding hopefully,
allow buying that game theory
offers a basic understanding
of the goal of E-con systems.
The second part is,
a lot of the systems
we developed,
especially in
understanding the economy,
you don't have to combine in this
new [inaudible] activate that.
National equilibrium
is very stable,
like that the state of the word,
kind of understanding of how to
[inaudible] . The current state
is everyone using data,
everyone reacting to data.
That's not how it works.
So, there is
interesting challenges.
Challenges that I think again
many of us are working on.
What happens if I take
the Nash kind of
equilibrium like these
but combined it with that the
player are all reacting to data,
that they're all
learning and develop,
extend this theory
in this direction,
which I think another thing
we need to do.
>> So, is your guess
that these ideas
will come from the field
itself or that
we need just like Nash was
coming completely
from left field as,
>> I think a lot of,
>> Abstract mathematician.
>> People who are completely
working on this right now,
are more coming from
Computer Science.
So, I don't think they're
coming from left field
because the E-con CS
interface's so strong.
So, I get this lab is
an example of such things
are happening,
but there was
a whole conference out
there under the name of
Economics and Computing,
where a lot of these people
get together there.
NIPS, which is one of
the big Machine
Learning conferences
last year had a workshop
on learning and games.
Even NIPS community
recognizes that this is
an interesting application of
[inaudible] . Learning again,
sort of happening also
but I said the fact that
NIPS hosted one them.
Except NIPS as a community,
understood the importance
of working in this area.
>> Madhu, do you have
thoughts about this?
>> So, first a little bit
about when you say,
"If things are working well
then why do we need theory?"
>> Yes.
>> The fact that things
are working well say
something about the past and it
says about problems that we've
encountered in the past,
where we're able to solve them.
I mean, even a company
like Microsoft
likes to think about
the future and say well,
"We're going to sell this piece
of hardware, this software,
this platform" It
should be working
any years into the future and
when you want to have
this predictability,
you do have to have a theory.
It might be very elementary,
not the most sophisticated stuff
that we're always working with,
but it should be able to
have some predictive power,
and this is roughly what we are
always working, striving towards.
The simpler the
predictive power gets,
the more theoretical the answer.
That's my definition of
theory, beauty, everything.
The more we can actually say,
take an idea and apply it in
multiple situations.
This is good.
So, the other handicap
that's working with
the problem that you are
set today is you forget
about the potential
generalizations
of a solution that you
may have discovered.
>> Yes.
>> I mean of course,
Machine Learning is an entire
theory of generalizability.
But I would even say that, "Look,
this is what drives
all of our theoretical
inspiration." We want to take
ideas from here applied there.
In order to go from
this point to that point,
we have to find
some common abstraction which
actually combines these two,
but also ends up including
a lot more than the four.
So, I think theory
is interesting and I
consider any work which
does this kind of
an abstraction theoretical.
I mean anything that we
can teach is theoretical.
Something that is
not living purely in
a system that we have hard coded,
which I cannot ever
remember again is,
as Yael was describing.
Those are not theory for me.
But when we can try to
abstract something,
go beyond the limits of what
has been described today.
Those are fantastic
things with theory.
So, I think this is what we
are striving for simple ideas
which explain a lot and
have the potential or
the possibility to explain
a lot into the future.
One more point and then
I'll pass it over.
I mean, a comment
that I heard from
a statistician recently and
I just loved it when I heard it,
was "All models are
wrong, some are useful."
>> Great. Perhaps
this is a moment to,
if you're still or
you're already awake,
to get a few questions
from the audience,
and we can try to get
the next round of reactions.
I think-. Either a microphone.
Is there? Yeah, yes.
>> We have two.
>> Yeah, we don't
even have to run.
>> Hi, well, thank you very
much, that's very great.
Okay, I'm Perisa, I'm
recent PhD graduate
from Boston University,
and I recently joined industry.
So, I've worked in
machine learning,
and information theory both and,
to me information theory is
one of those beautiful ideas,
because once is proven
no one can say it's wrong,
and so I feel like,
it shows the path to the future,
and because you said,
"We need prediction for all
these learning algorithms."
I was wondering, what
is the connection
between these two films,
because, maybe
information theory,
could be a useful tool
for predicting what
are their limits
of any specific architectures
of learning algorithms,
what do you think
about this? Thank you.
>> We'll come back to it,
let's see whether there
are other questions.
Can we get somebody
to, yes you go.
>> It's such another question,
it's that common because,
I think it relates a lot
to the last statement,
and to decrease
the number of objectives.
Actually because the model
cited as an interpretation
of the world.
IT some artists that are using
economics models as a way
to interpret or express
their own vision of the world,
and then they actually
tweet them and
caricature them as an abstract
or as an impressionist
will actually tie
his own personality during
the interpretation of the world,
and so the economic model
actually become a form
of art in terms of
interpreting the world.
>> Somewhat beautiful as well.
Great comments. I need
[inaudible] , okay.
>> Chrispus from Cambridge.
I wonder if you could
say a little about
the communication between
theorists and not themselves
but the consumers of the theory.
One thought I have in mind is,
machine learning but I
wouldn't consider myself a
Theorist but I'm interested
in the consumer theory
if you like.
One piece of theory from
the second wave of neural nets,
was the theorem
that two layers of
neurons are sufficient to
approximate any function
to arbitrary accuracy,
and of course it's a it's
a proven rigorous theorem
so it's correct it's not going to
change and yet it's
perhaps it did it
distracts people from
thinking about deep learning,
how should we
interpret the theory?
>> Hmm.
>> That's my question.
>> Great yes it's
a wonderful question.
Any other and then we
do another around.
Yeah, we'll come to it, yeah.
Great so I would
like to start with
this kind of last question
which I can almost rephrase.
So there are many elements
to it that I want
to come back to.
Perhaps the first
first that you know.
Sometimes, theory can suggest
something and then progress being
made go round in something
right so it could be.
So anybody wants to,
perhaps succintly answer
that question why
the two-layer network didn't
prevent thinking for learning.
>> Sorry, none of us is probably
an expert at this level.
>> You don't need
to be qualified to
give an understandable answer.
>> One thing that I
see definitely is that
when we answer questions
in the theory land,
they are often
precisely formulated,
we answer the precise question
that was asked,
but then there was something
else in the background saying
"Oh but I always meant
something else,"
and that was not abstracted
into the question and
the answer completely fails
to get to that point.
So, there is a constant
interaction which is why you know
it's not the case that every
theoretical paper sort
of changes the world.
There is a constant interaction
between the applications
and the theory in
these kinds of settings and
many times I would suspect
in the deep neural nets,
and also we forgot
some aspect of,
yes we wanted to
maybe approximate
every function but
it also has to be
learnable by
some simple mechanism,
the kinds of data that is
available may not be captured by
the kind of data that
was used to prove
the depth to the result.
So, we have lots of
different possibilities
on what could vary.
The interesting aspect
of theory is that
we throw away a lot of
these details in order
to solve the problem but
the details start to become
important and rise to
prominence once you've
solved the first problem.
>> I guess by taking
extreme limits
we all agree the world is
just run by theorists,
not goods, and not all
theorists are good often.
So somehow in between.
Can any of you say
something about what
should be kind of
the right ecosystem.
It's almost like how to
structure a world where there is
all these different
kind of niches
and how should they communicate.
>> Yeah.
>> Do you have
some ideas about this?
>> Yeah, so actually my main area
of research is photography that's
exactly nearing where does
theory of cryptography,
but then people actually use
cryptography and there is
kind of a very
interesting executives
ecosystem of, sorry,
of the theorists on the one
hand and someone should
try to move from take
things from theory
land to practice land,
and that is actually
very, very important.
This kind of middle person,
these middle people were
supposed to deliver.
Is a very, very important group
and I think that that
part is actually tough.
As the theorists we're
a strong community.
>> You have to be bilingual.
>> Exactly, you need
to be bilingual.
The theory community
[inaudible] application of
the people who applied
things are strong but,
in the middle of the people
that actually move,
and the reason is I think
exactly what Madison, first,
often you know we have models,
for me something efficient is
polynomial-time computable
that's how I define efficiency.
>> It's not as
somebody who's yes-.
>> Back to your basic statement,
that not everyone
should be a Theorist
I teach at the University
for a living.
This semester I'm
teaching algorithms
there's 300 kids that's
the required course
so next semester
Bobby Kleinberg gets to
do this and that's combined
[inaudible] class.
I do actually want
every single damn
computer scientists
to understand the basic thing,
and the same way Econ 101 [inaudible]
or whatever the level courses
teach against
Syria Nash equilibrium to
every economist at
every university.
Yeah, sure definitely
if you take theory
that's getting developed in
the last 10 years
or so right now,
and if that's going
up short-term or
immediate or in the next
10 years in the industry,
then definitely am
not objecting to
the people who are worse
than both sets and
your question was like
that because this is
a developing theorem.
But at the end, I do want
some basic theory by
basic understanding to actually
migrate to literally everyone
researching the field,
then I guess I'll do
that for a living.
>> But I think Robert
wasn't saying that he
wasn't saying that everyone
should understand basic theory,
he was saying that
not everybody should
be a Theorist so, you know.
>> Or we can capture that.
I think that was the idea,
you can have a beautiful theorem
that kind of finishes
the fields so
to say and that
actually the field
can go around it then
we have many examples.
>> So what-.
>> But I actually agree
this module that we
definitely didn't finish
the theory in the sense
that the event as
that theorem was
developed They did know that
training that they had then,
they have no idea how to do it.
They don't have a theory of
light that's trainable so,
we sort of reason
why [inaudible].
>> Uh-hmm.
>> That was already
an open question.
It was a simple model.
But, there are
the shorter term impact,
which is already long term
for our industry 10 years,
and then there is
the really long-term impact.
Yeah, of course,
not everyone should work on
the longest long-term
theory even to
live to the further
advance that theory.
Help make that progress happen.
But, I think we need to strive
at some basic theory and
elegant beautiful theories that
explain a lot of what's
going on in the world.
That should be out there with
every practicing engineer.
>> Mike, do you agree on that?
>> Yeah. I was just going to say,
I think one way to put it,
is that people should think
like theorists, in a way.
So, that if theory forces you
to understand what are the key
things I want to focus on,
I can't do everything at once.
So, I have to distill things into
some set of variables that I
think are going to
really be important,
and then I have to
attack the problem
in a systematic way.
I think, obviously,
research is faddish,
and it makes sense
that people go all to,
now there's an intense interest
in machine learning,
and it makes sense for a lot
of people to be working on it,
and there's synergies there.
But, at the same time,
pattern recognition isn't going
to be the only thing that works,
you have to know
what you're looking
for and, as Madhu said,
you're thinking about the future,
the system is going to change.
So, you need some structure
of how is the system
going to change,
how do I make predictions
about the future in
completely unseen versions
of the current world.
>> We're talking about
long-term thinking.
So, clearly now we're in
the first decades of the lap,
so 10 years seems
to be a lifetime.
But, if you look at
your own fields and something,
so what is the lifespan
of truly deep ideas?
Are we talking
about many decades?
Then, the question comes now,
how do we sustain
these kind of ideas?
I love the idea Madhu was saying,
there's something theory is also
very helpful because it's
something you can teach,
that you can transfer
to the next generation,
which is very difficult
from just experiences.
There were some ideas about
what the time-span is,
and what's necessary to bridge
that, these long-time intervals.
How do you keep a theory
alive, so to say?
>> Okay. I think here we defer to
the sociological aspects
of the field,
and let the people
more or less decide.
I have sociologists friends
in the audience.
For the most part, we just
tend to leave this to
personal taste and
the activity levels
that is sustainable via field.
>> Are these personal choices
completely independent?
Because there is, to some extent,
driven by external factors.
>> Absolutely. I
think we have to see
the questions that are
driving the field.
We have to see some of
the ability to make
progress on the
questions just saying,
here are problems that
have been open for
the last 500 years and
we're going to work
on this for the next 10 years.
Doesn't seem to be a good way.
Well, the good news about
even this kind of an approach,
I could try this approach,
and I will not be able to recruit
students into this field.
So, I think there is
a pretty strong phenomenon
where students,
the new people
entering the field,
tend to also take us in
different directions and
this often ends up being
the most primal force.
So, who can we recruit?
Today, we see
excellent people who
have trained as theoretical
computer scientists
drifting towards
machine learning.
Why is this happening?
Because there are
important problems,
there are challenges there.
We're not going to drop
everything we know.
But, we're not going to work
on the same old problems
necessarily when there are
so many other compelling things.
So, this is a live field in its.
>> There are some young people
here in the audience,
and I can trigger any of
the graduate students here,
or something, what they
think about the role
of theory and long-term issues.
I see a graduate student
right there.
>> I am not a grad student,
but just a quick comment.
I love the panel, by the way,
give you a quick scenario,
which is little bit different.
We were hammering
on a problem since
1998 on ideal Web crawl,
and it's gone through
some theories,
some practice, empirical tests.
We've finally hit upon the most
theoretical analysis of this,
and it's the most practical
and going into service.
It took us literally,
we do it kind
of constantly, but
intermittently,
hammering on this for 20 years,
and only having a lab like this
and thank God, Redmond
is 27 years old.
Well, we actually fostered
different teams of [inaudible] in
this case they're working
with [inaudible] and so on.
We got to the theory
that was most practical,
if it kind of pushed on this.
>> It's fantastic to hear.
>> I would like to
give you an example of
a good case of long-term
thinking, which actually,
was at the Institute
for Advanced Study,
the mathematician
Vladimir Voevodsky,
who unfortunately
passed away last year.
But, he was a great
algebraic geometer,
got the Fields medal,
then found a mistake
in one of his papers.
He was very surprised
to find a mistake,
but even more surprised
that nobody cared.
Then, he thought, well, I have to
rewrite the foundations
of mathematics,
so that the computers
can actually understand,
in his case, abstract
homotopy theory.
So, he then spent 10 years,
essentially without
producing any paper.
I would say it's like a
whale diving very deep,
and then at some point,
you're worried, well,
will he come back to the surface.
He did, and I think it was
quite the successful program,
and it might have a big impact,
but it makes me think,
do we have places
where somebody can
be underwater for 10 years?
>> Yeah, that's something.
>> In the end, we all benefit.
When he was not
producing anything,
are you worried that he
would have come out I
think well if somebody spends
10 years thinking about it,
and you find a common result,
you have a 10-year advantage,
which is terrific too.
>> It's an amazing example,
and there are other
amazing examples that are
also less amazing and
less famous examples
to spend 10 years.
>> [inaudible].
>> Eva, can you save
that story for later?
>> I really like that our field,
and actually your field also,
economics and theoretical
computer science.
When you write a paper,
you have to start by explaining
some sort of long-term thing.
Good research doesn't necessarily
solve the fundamental problem
of the field of
the universe because there are
very few results of that sort.
So, most days, day
in and day out,
each of us cannot or I
cannot produce
results of that sort.
But, I have to write
an introduction that explains,
why do you need to care about,
why is this the step in
a possible direction
where there is
a big hill that we
really care about?
I admit the machine learning
people now have it easy.
There is a very big clear
big hill over there.
But, everything we're working on,
we are constantly pushed
to explain the goal.
That's usually
interests of all of
our papers, and these ideas,
people sometimes do that,
and occasionally
they're successful,
but I think sometimes
they're less.
I really like that I'm
getting pushed and
I guess there is
one example from my early years
that I've been
pretty public about,
where I wrote a paper where in
the break after I gave the
talk László Lovász very,
very gently, and very
politely came over that,
"Yes, but why do you care?"
I was so embarrassed that
I can't defend myself,
that it took me, I forgot,
many years till I even
wrote down the result.
I did write it down,
it is actually published in
Journal of JCT, Journal.
>> Combinatorial Theory.
Thank you. So, it
was a hard paper,
but I think I learned a lesson,
and this is the lesson I promote,
is that we need to think
even before we get involved.
Why do we care?
I guess he knew why he
cared because he was
so famous and well established.
The community trusted him.
But, I think the fact that
we regularly have to write
about our partial results and
explain that this is a good core,
has two giant benefits; one,
it makes us think about
this which is good;
and second, we
recruit our friends,
or our colleagues to help.
These much of the results
that we're achieving,
they're not a single
person's achievement.
It's anything that the
two of them talked
about for crypto,
from error-correcting code,
there's a community
working on this.
>> Yeah, you want
to add something.
>> Yeah. So, I think
the long-term is that,
I agree with you completely
that you need to have
a goal in mind that you
think is worth going for.
But, now, the goal can
be one that you think
that will take you
a long time to achieve or one
that you just want to pay for
because we need your penny.
Clearly we need both
because like you said,
life is happening now
and you want to advance.
But, also clearly we
want the long-term one
because that's where the joy,
the really big community
ideas come from.
Some of us, I'm not saying all,
every one of those scholarship
should spend now,
go 10 years underwater,
and think deeply.
But, some people
should because we need
some good ideas and it's
dangerous, I agree with you.
You can sink in and die there.
So, it is a dangerous journey.
But I think that's where
it's an important one,
and that's where a lot of
wonderful things happen.
>> Actually, one comment on that,
I think look,
stepping back a bit,
when we think about
who supports research?
Why they support it and
what their goals are?
That's a very difficult part of
research because
there's a huge value in
these deep dives and
new discoveries that are
going to be transformative
many years later.
Often those aren't the ones
that are going to have
immediate payoffs.
You need large
benevolent organizations
like Microsoft, or universities,
or something that are
willing to fund labs,
that allow people to take
deep dives and that's not-
>> I noticed that people who do
a completely different
financial investment.
Often, they have a risk project.
They have to really spend
so many percentage of
risk and they can do it.
They can distribute it in their-.
[inaudible].
They have a risk budget and
they really measure so to say,
the level of risky and
that risky investment.
I don't think
actually we do this,
at least not in a very
conscious supported way.
>> Exactly.
>> Should we do it or?
>>Yeah. I think that
somehow it's difficult that
research is done in
a very self-organized system.
It's people out there just
doing what they want.
There are some incentives,
and [inaudible] and tenure,
and you have to keep
producing at some level.
You have to justify
what you're doing.
There's landmarks and goals,
but the overall picture
of how we're invested
and who's doing what,
there's very little coordination.
It's just like a lot of
humans like ants marching
around all doing their thing and
hoping that we coordinate
and produce good things.
There's enough of us that
good things happen but.
>> Does any of you believe
that it's an optimal
distribution?
>> I'm very wary of any form
of metrics being used to
determine what's a good research
and who is a good researcher.
One of the things that you
have to keep in mind is
that we are taking a wide
spectrum of people over here,
and then going to the
very, very, very,
tail ends to determine,
"These are the people who
want to be researchers."
Applying the theory of
predictability which is
supposed to be somewhere
sitting around the middle
of the bell curve to
a population which is sitting at
the extreme seems to be
completely dangerous to me.
Unfortunately, this is getting
practiced too commonly
in universities,
tenure systems,
promotion cases, etc.
We really have to
be wary about it.
Everyone of us knows by
personal familiarity
that the people
that they admire were
not the ones who,
sort of, is the metrics.
These are the ones
that came up with
the brilliant ideas and probably
came up with the brilliant ideas
almost out of nowhere.
At the same time to see,
"Should we now try to
manage this process,"
is very dangerous.
I love by the way
the Microsoft motto or
principles by which
they were hiring,
and they were managing
the research labs which was,
"We decide who we hire,
we don't decide what they do."
I think it was
a wonderful principle and
I hope they're going
to continue this.
It was when I was here and
after that if you like.
>> I think it's fair to say
that both that principle
and the long-term goal,
and it's great to be here with
an organization that values this.
I hear a lot of complaints
that in some sense
that open space is shrinking.
That for instance, 50 years ago,
even big famously at
Bell Labs and a lot
of places that were
producing many,
many Nobel Prizes,
and somehow had
more oxygen or something
than typically now
you see around.
Any of you agree,
is the world getting better,
it's getting different,
what's happening?
>>I think that at
the end of the day,
you're asking
whether there should
be a managing research?
I completely agree with
Michael 100 percent.
There is a difference by
definition because you
need money for it
and someone needs to
decide how to
distribute the money.
That new distribution is
a definition of what the world
think of us, important.
I mean importance is
where the money goes,
so that's [inaudible] . There
is such a thing happening
by necessity in a sense.
>> I think humans are good
at reacting to crisis.
They're not good at
long-term investments,
and that's a really
difficult thing to do.
To say, "Look, we
want to fund this.
It's going to be great.
Let all these people take
deep dives and we'll see
30 years from now what happens."
Instead you're looking at,
"We've got this pressing problem
and let's solve it."
It's a very difficult thing
to do and the funding becomes
essential because these things
can't be done without
that funding.
>> I want to object,
there are two issues
we are raising,
the deep dive as in
going into an area which
doesn't produces
interesting and amazing things
and not necessarily
have immediate impact,
and that you have to
do it all by yourself.
I don't think you have to
I think the pressure
to publish or pressure to talk
about pressure resilience,
and sometimes some people
take it the wrong
way and work on something that
doesn't have a long-term
goal and I object.
The positive impact of
the very same thing is
that when you publish
your pressure is that
two words every goal then
usually there's a whole community
out there who suddenly sees that,
"Good point, the goal
might be reachable.
Let me welcome this."
There's a whole part there.
Your pressure is that,
they're recruiting a community
which is not against
the main goal, idea.
>> I think we are
getting close to the end
of the first- Perhaps
one more question.
Yes, please. Then we'll finish.
>> Do you think the lag will
change now that people
are communicating better,
there's no necessary
a 30 year lag between
the time that
somebody has a great
theoretical result
and it's applied?
>> Perhaps that's a good
question and then I'll finish
by each ask you
a very short question about,
what's the future of thinking,
of how do you see.
Perhaps mention one element
that might change
the nature of theory,
the nature of long-term thinking
when we are looking
in the future.
If you're here in
10 years celebrating
10 years [inaudible]
what will be different?
>> Let me make
a quick answer to Adam,
and this actually Kevin
Leyton-Brown is in
the audience and
we've done two MOOCs together.
I think now the dissemination of
knowledge is really amazing.
Being able to teach
game theory to
people around the world in
a large scale that they would
never have had access to,
means that there's
a very different landscape.
That we don't quite
understand yet,
but it's very very encouraging
when people who otherwise
would have no access to
this knowledge can now
become part of the team,
become recruited, and help
producing future knowledge that's
going to advance the society.
>> [inaudible].
>> Also a quick reaction
to Adam's question,
I think as we're
communicating faster,
I'd say not necessarily better,
one of the advantages is
of course you hear
all the good news very quickly,
also hear all the fake
news very quickly.
This does not apply
only to realms
like politics and society,
it's also applying to
scientific results.
We all heard about the proof of
the Riemann hypothesis
a few weeks back,
and these kinds of events.
We do have to worry a lot about,
there is a lot of
material being generated.
Simply the volume is very high.
Even if you have
infinite bandwidth coming in,
there is a limited bandwidth
going into my brain.
I think we're going to have,
this will be
a process which will,
somethings become better,
maybe your geographical
distance from the center of
the discovery is no
longer as relevant.
But having intellectual mass
at a place where you are is
still going to be relevant.
You are alone in
this isolated place,
you can be very
well-connected on the web to
every piece of development
and still not really get it.
>> Eva. One short.
>> I think I love Adam's comment
and I think that's
[inaudible] of the future
to connect the
Machine learning is
an excellent barrier
where this is really
happening more powerfully.
By the time people submit
their paper and machine
learning to NIPS or [inaudible]
usually tests on
these same number of
citations because they
put it on archive first.
People are already
starting to work
on follow-up and using it.
It is amazing and I think,
I don't know if we'd
be ever as fast
as the machine
learning community is,
but this speed of
people reacting to
each other's idea improving.
I think we'll help science
go further faster.
>> Yes.
>> No, it's okay [inaudible].
>> Okay, terrific.
Well I want to thank
all of you for
being awake and participating.
I think in the self-congratulatory
nature of academics,
we want to celebrate
this wonderful institution here
and happy 10th anniversary.
>>Thank you. Let's
thank the panel.